[Music]
do you spend time with your family
good
because a man who doesn't spend time
with his family can never be a real man
you can do anything but never go against
the family
[Music]
the strength of a family like the
strength of an army lies in its loyalty
to each other
[Music]
keep your friends close but your enemies
closer
i work my whole life i don't apologize
to take care of my family i don't
apologize that's my life
she's very beautiful to you she's
beautiful for me there's only my wife
and son
[Music]
a man who is not a father to his
children can never be a real man
[Music]
a friend should always underestimate
your virtues and an enemy overestimate
your faults
falling in love is great but being in
love is a disaster
[Music]
any man can turn traitor
[Music]
some honorable men spend their whole
lives preparing for a supreme act of
treachery
[Music]
we are all honorable men here we do not
have to give each other assurances as if
we were lawyers
[Music]
the lawyer with the briefcase can steal
more money than the man with the gun
[Music]
behind every successful fortune there is
a crime
many young men started down a false path
to their true destiny
time and fortune usually set them all
right
never let anyone know what you are
thinking
power wears out those who do not have it
[Music]
when they come
they come at what you love
i spent my whole life trying not to be
careless
women and children can afford to be
careless
men cannot
men in general sooner forget the loss of
their matrimony than the death of their
father
he should be careful it's dangerous to
be an honest man
like many businessmen of genius he
learned that free competition was
wasteful
monopoly efficient
you live like a fool and you have come
to a fool's end
none of us here wants to see our
children follow in our footsteps
it's too hard a life
your love is also your weak point
the richest man is the one with the most
powerful friends
even the strongest man needs friends
[Music]
men understand friendship more than
women do
[Music]
as i am a reasonable man i'm willing to
do whatever is necessary to find a
peaceful solution to these problems
don't raise your voice improve your
argument
[Music]
i have learned more in the streets than
in any classroom
good health is the most important thing
more than success more than money more
than power
[Music]
each man has his own destiny
time erodes gratitude more quickly than
it does beauty
i respect those who tell me the truth no
matter how hard it is
[Music]
in this world there comes a time when
the most humble of men
if he keeps his eyes open
can take his revenge on the most
powerful of men
friendship is everything friendship is
more than talent it is more than the
government
it is almost the equal of family
i raised my daughter in the american
fashion i gave her freedom but i taught
her never to dishonor her family
[Music]
italians have a little joke
that the world is so hard a man must
have two fathers to look after him
and that's why they have godfathers
my father is no different than any man
with power
like a president or a senator
[Music]
do not count on the gratitude of deeds
done for people in the past
you must make them grateful for things
you will do for them in the future
[Music]
your enemies always get strong on what
you leave behind
revenge is a dish best served cold
[Music]
never hate your enemies it affects your
judgment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you